hai capito dove stiamo dando prodotto
fare dalla mamma cuttino avrete visto
che abbiamo già giocato una mamma
cattiva bombonera di verterà la molla
virtuale che signora ricorda però questa
volta l skype room della bomba cattiva
su roma
mi raccomando la stato un bel mi piace
va sotto per portarsi fortuna e per fare
in modo che ci sposiamo almeno questo è
un giorno tutto orecchini di oggi il mio
amatissimo a votarlo ammette il tipico
di brand di bocca
eccoci qua è la mamma cattiva e dice
stai giocando è arrabbiata perché il
figlio immagino e lui dice no perché
mamma
in effetti guarda sto giocando l'escape
room di robles anche quella della
prigione vero gioco dietro gioco che
capiamo capiamo subito inizia bene
dobbiamo saltare su di gioco più bello
che sono porta ok ma attraversato la
porta e misure sfracellata civile che ti
disprezza e l'altro no mi ha fatto
vedere il mio outfit corrisponde un po
il mio outfit attuale di oggi quindi il
cerchietto bianco è un vestito bianco
stivali bianchi e stranamente anche
evitare cambiato output finalmente a una
maglietta verde loro nozze per chi sente
questo è luminoso mi piaceva era bello e
verde e invertono il viaggio è vitale ha
cambiato un pò stile però la faccia
abbiamo vediamo se questi nuovi vestiti
li porteranno fortuna in questo schifo
rosa c'è scritto questa torta è stata
chiusa quindi di visitare l'altra porta
nel drago e dai buy prima giu io vado
con quella centrale non è così
[Musica]
proviamo questo vediamo voi se avete
detto che sia un trucchetto cioè di
guardare sotto per vedere se si passa
attraverso quindi quello centrale
dovrebbe essere questo lato la seconda
no no ai quarti passato l'aquila si la
centrale era bombe ricordate questo no
ok abbiamo fatta prossimo
ma non c'è solo una porta le altre sono
bloccate ma è tipo labirinto delle tv di
male se non fosse che sono sganciate dai
non è difficile mi caduto di nuovo che
ho parlato troppo presto oggetto non è
difficile almeno dei fiori quarzo
filtrare questo schifo roomster un sacco
di cose eco vitale ce la farà sì siccome
non ce la faccio ultima
[Musica]
dai bruno e l'ultimo fatto lei inizia a
vedere come sono questi fiori buche per
cento sono con ozil no mare continua a
cantare rtv dai puoi farcela città è
l'ultimo l'ultimo gioco su vitale non si
è sfracellato ancora troppo strano ci
scrivo dobbiamo andare dentro alla
caverna
l'importante che non mentre la bocca di
quartiere
avete visto in altri sei pronta per ora
dice non toccare la lava quindi il
pavimento della va piano piano per far
parte tetto pianissimo
wow
ce l'ho fatta anche vitale e divertente
questo è stranamente non sembra così
difficile fino adesso parla quello che
si dà a pragelato fa ma chi parlare
troppo presto simpatico noi salviamo
sdoppia tra smembrando sta andando
avanti coi sensi entra militare ma ci
sono delle particelle di lava che escono
fuori dappertutto meglio che stare
attenti io sono solo bordo i normali
fantasmi che abitano in casa hanno
chiuso una delle porte vi verrebbe data
abbassa la festa che una perdita nel
nella nella caverna di sopra la lava
piano piano offre ancora più stretto
stare qua qua dentro
abbiamo dentro un avente una via
d'uscita non so perché ma è un pochino
incastrata che succede ok sono riuscita
a disintegrarsi in un labirinto stradini
ma è veramente il nostro però almeno
fatemi torni si è abbastanza facile
adesso siamo usciti stiamo tornando
indietro e dove se non ha vinto l'asta è
giusto brava ma che brava e che chiede
che succede nello spoglio reale
risognato propria città dove capitale
essere soltanto sette le casse di legno
su un liquido urlai moso che niente
meglio non cadere la scocca è stato
proprio delle belle cuffie in effetti sì
ma cosa ci fanno delle cuffie giganti
qua lo slime allora dobbiamo ci sarà
nuovamente nei mente
fatemi uscire dai sembra facile che
cos'è come mi dite
guardo no ti prego non fa più la madre
gatti non esiste o no siamo scappati
anche dalla babysitter dunque ecco qua è
la mamma cattiva gigante da quello che
ha detto vitale vista che siamo stati
mangiati
vediamo che cosa ha mangiato perché ogni
volta scopriamo che cosa ha mangiato
anche lei ha mangiato le cose inter
eto'o masticato una foglia di insalata
intera giallo che cos'è vabbè due
lattine vitale
su rai4 la tua parte preferita la
riconosciuta al colonia
qual è il tuo pezzo preferito nola
ebbene sì siamo proprio lì e se si è un
po diverso dal solito
mi piace che lo ha scritto che puzza
tantissimo qua niente è come sembra
ancora kakà diara le cure
[Musica]
[Applauso]
torino 3 2 una via a piedi non riesco
più a bordo è lunghissimo
ecco qualcosa mi dice che sarà super di
fare ma che cosa è successo
siamo rimasti intrappolati a tu sei
proprio hubble dentro
hai capito dove stiamo nel water
però ci sono problemi fatto vedere
questa cosa è perché mi hai fatto finire
con riusciamo di spartito siamo stati
non so se si può dire che si prova a
uscire si porta è meglio scappare il più
velocemente possibile adesso dove stiamo
nel bagno forse ma è allagata e si è
allagato il bagno
aiuto ecco la mamma si è rallegrato il
bagno allora lui dice a bravi ritrovato
una perdita nel gabinetto ha quindi noi
siamo scappati gradoni al buco nel
gabinetto abbastanza piccolo per scappa
sarà sotto la porta che riguarda il topo
ed una bomba cattiva è arrabbiatissima
anche per al bar avviata attraverso
questo tunnel
la casetta del topo questa è come tom e
jerry no al 3 con ronnie che cos'è ma si
deve saltare sono tanti tobini che forse
dobbiamo evitarli
casomai con la loro cosa ci si forte
siamo vicini all'uscita
abbiamo passato la parte peggiore è
attento sono riuscito a uscire ma così
ancora sui formaggi sono i triangolini
di formata dai tuoi paris e nei due
forse siamo
wow la frazione è finito ci hanno dato
il ben
ma guarda proprio la donna a casa entro
la prigione descritto e vito è triste ma
posso mangiare quella torta
lasciate un bel mi piace già cadere
altre che pur rom questo è stato troppo
diverse io soprattutto per quella parte
del gabinetto 4 casellina su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione
ciao